you ready to party or what I don't mind
if I
whoa
dang you're two shots behind
lanetti two bottles of vodka is this
going to be the weekend we finally meet
six drink Amy six drink Amy what does
that mean it's the Pinnacle of the
Santiago drunkenness scale one drink
Amy's a little spy wait what two drinks
loud Amy you want to get a cat
Amy you got to be glad that Holt's here
right I mean you're basically in love
with him I love him I'm not in love with
him but I'm definitely not comfortable
being drunk around him am please keep
the volume down okay sorry it's two
drinks I can't help it that's it I'm
cutting myself off so Jake messes up and
you punish me for it come on Amy you're
better than that three drinks Amy dance
pan Kevin no how are you here you called
me you didn't stop calling me I didn't
call you look you left 17 voicemails
here's one H you got to come save us we
need a lie to get you here Charles what
should I say that I got shot in the face
oh and tell him to bring pizza woo K ho
we're losing yeah why are you dancing oh
I was up to n Amy who speaks French and
then I
Hur I Hur H what she's trying to say is
that she vomited and now she's back down
to three drink Amy or Amy dance pants
you know
it my God Hitchcock are you the only
person still making sense yeah it's bad
so cold even my fiery dance moves aren't
keeping me warm the trick is you got to
be prepared mini conac lady oh
yeah me up you little bastard full of
drinks thank you Terry's Fanny and thank
you
posidon great god of the
sea Bo drink Amy is a bit of a pervert
hey check it
out what are you wearing
t-shirt I only brought a bikini it seems
weird to be in front of the captain a
bathing suit got to cover up them things
yeah FYI you can still see them for your
shirt so here we all are finally
relaxing as a squad together in the tub
it's fun huh I can't hear anyone can we
please turn off the Jets
yeah
that's was better no more Disturbed
water good call wow without the bubbles
you can really see everything eyes up
here
Peralta Amy where you at for drinks
what's for drink Amy again why don't you
come over here and find out right horny
Amy feels like you should retire that
one for the me too era lch come over
here and make me the boring halt party
will be in the living room at least
three of us must be with him in that
room at all times it's not a party if
there aren't four people especially
Between the Sheets
and under it bangang names names you
don't want to be around H in your
current state say hello to the most
confident woman
alive drink number
five you are a true friend and a hot
little
piece goodbye for drink Amy sloppy sicko
and five drink Amy is weirdly confident
let's do this little man
his name
is Blair Underwood the man I saw in the
grocery store is Blair Underwood hey Ray
it's time for what detective San dieago
you to give me a promotion and a 40%
raise I've been carrying the squad for 2
years and my back's getting tired yeah
excuse me Captain hey Amy can I talk to
you for one second uh you just did burn
ah so good so listen I don't think
overconfidence and Amy is working out
maybe you should go back downstairs
maybe I should just have another drink
get ready America Here Comes six okay
that's but I've never seen six drink Amy
maybe she's the one I could actually be
friends with AKA my Sasquatch six drink
am so alone oh no 16 am isn't Fun she's
just sad damn it ases
Gina you got to see the Sasquatch was it
everything you Dred it was the stuff
drums are made of can you hold my eyes
still till things stop spinning okay
let's sit you up there easy do there oh
there you go now drink this entire glass
of water you're taking care of me just
cuz I know you won't remember it mm-
nope you like me six drink Amy is your
friend and and she's going to be very
sick right now okay the Buffalo PD
always throws an insane party last year
Amy got so drunk she jumped a police
horse into the pool at drink Amy is an
equestrian and she's real bad at it and
that is why Christy and the snobs is the
best babysitters club book ever hey we
should go fly fishing sometime that's
never going to happen we need to sober
you up and get you back out there coffee
and carbs us works so here's what we're
going to do ow Rosa what about the carbs
that was a misdirection carbs never work
slapping is the only way I think it
worked and I just want to say what makes
Christy and the snob so good is the snob
their names are Tiffany and Shannon and
they laugh at Lou even though he's going
blind which is so sad okay I'm calling H
this is a failure no wait wait I have an
idea oh I bet it's great okay you know
how guys like OS Sullivan they think we
all look the same right so you dress as
zamy you take my place and oh my oh my
God is n drink Amy a genius that's never
going to work you just need to sober up
and get back out there oh you're on the
floor this is Captain H oh hello Captain
it's Amy Santiago Sergeant are you drunk
oh you thinks I'm drunk what do I do uh
British accent smart that'll fool him
yes sir quite drunk wankered
really